So for 300 years in this country,
there was really no such thing as fair
food,
meaning that there was no way to
recognize from a consumer's purchases
that workers were treated well in the
thirties,
forties,
and fifties.
A movement started in California,
lead eventually by Dolores Huerta and
Cesar Chavez that morphed into the
United Farm Workers Union and people of
a certain age,
my age and above,
um,
can remember not eating grapes or
lettuce in the seventies because of the
nationwide boycotts against produce that
wasn't picked fairly,
that wasn't picked in those days by
union members.
Now,
unions have been decimated all across
the countries and the eighties and
nineties.
Most of the union protections that were
won by farm workers were rolled back.
Farmworkers have two things against
them.
Number one,
in many states,
most workers can't unionize without the
fear of losing their job.
In Florida,
for example,
it's a right to work state,
which means euphemistically,
that if you decide to unionize,
your employer can fire you just for
that.
In California,
for example,
they can't fire you because you are
trying to organize a union.
Secondly,
according to the National Labor
Standards Act that was set in 1938 by
FDR that set the minimum wage
requirements for workers all across the
country,
farm workers were the exception.
Farm workers and domestic workers were
predominantly African American,
and in order for Fdr to pass that bill,
he needed the support of the southern
Democrats who refuse to let their
African Americans have the same rights
that workers all across the nation we're
having,
so farm workers and domestic workers
were excluded from that.
So fast forward to the present,
day and age,
there are no unions.
Farm workers aren't really protected by
national labor laws.
They definitely aren't entitled to
overtime.
And what that means is that for consumer
who's asking themselves,
is my food fair?
The answer 99 point nine,
nine,
nine percent of the time is either no or
there's no way to tell.
My film.
Food chains focuses on one small group
of workers from central Florida.
Southern Florida really called the
coalition of immokalee workers.
Amockley isn't a native American word,
which means our home and it's a little
tiny labor camp in southern Florida
right next to Naples and I call it a
labor camp because it's got a um,
wintertime population of 40,000 people
when the harvest is in full swing,
but there is no city council.
There's no mayor,
there's no real infrastructure in that
city and it's only 15 miles away from
the richest zip code in America,
Naples.
So in Macula is a labor camp.
And in that little labor camp,
some of the worst atrocities in this
country have happened from modern day
slavery to sexual harassment,
to really her really horrific crimes in
the field,
but a little group called the ciw.
The coalition of immokalee workers
created a program called the fair food
program.
And that fair food program is really the
only program in the United States that
absolutely guarantees that workers in
the field earn more than sub poverty
level wages and are entitled to a
complete spectrum of human rights
guarantees.
They've gotten 12 major retailers to
sign onto that program.
And what that means in simple terms is
that if you go to Walmart,
whole foods,
trader Joe's,
if you eat it almost any fast food
restaurant in America,
except one ds in the wintertime,
most likely your tomato is from that
program.
It's a fair food tomato.
So if you want to eat fair,
you can go to whole foods,
you can go to Walmart.
Surprisingly,
you can go to trader Joe's and buy their
Florida tomatoes.
That's the only product in the entire
United States that's absolutely
guaranteed out a doubt to be fair labor.